Charlize Theron's yes is in the movie
with you yeah and what's it like working
with her uh she's phenomenal well
everyone knows she's a great great
actress but she's she's actually quite
inappropriate as well
she's inappropriate he's quite
inappropriate she way is she in a
program that's quite a potty mouth oh
yeah let's talk about that
well I were the very first time I I
can't even believe I'm telling you this
story the very first time I met her I
came on set she and joel edgerton were
having a conversation
mm-hmm bear in mind I have never met her
before and she does so David what's your
opinion on bleached ask
okay Andy's got pictures in every video
on my phone so yeah that will get your
attention
well yeah and the next thing I said is
hi I'm David yeah yeah and so she had
just she just kept bringing those up
throughout well she got she got quite a
kick out of sucking me all the time
probably the first time she showed that
she shocked you within she's like oh
this is gonna be fun
yeah and then she likes to wrap it up
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah so all sorts of
I said this was inappropriate sexual
positions naughty words to the point
whereby we actually use it in the film
there's that there's a moment she says I
would rather give that waiter a rim job
but a nicer and and my character says
what is the rim job yeah I still don't
know what a rim job is
[Applause]
I I have one video that will explain
both it's really good it's just good to
get it up right the images right now oh
boy
you